strung together in haste this makeshift
Camp lies on the outskirts of mali's
capital bamako it's been built by people
who've recently fled violence sweeping
the country
among them fatuma takunate she says when
Malian soldiers marched into her Village
he thought she would be safe but instead
they killed her husband she then
describes a wave of attacks carried out
by Fighters linked to al-Qaeda in
government-backed militias she says a
U.N peacekeeping force is based not far
away but has never come to protect the
people in her Village I
no longer safe
and the U.N soldiers they just come
after the battle look at what has
happened and then leave again
fourteen thousand unp's keeping troops
mostly from African nations are
stationed in Mali after French troops
intervened to stop armed groups from
invading the country in 2013 costing
nearly one billion dollars a year and
with more than 180 soldiers killed it's
the most expensive peacekeeping
operation carried out by the UN in terms
of money and the lives of its personnel
the U.N peacekeeping Mission also known
as minusma says it has the mandate to
protect the population ensure the peace
agreement is respected and assist Malian
authorities in building reconciliation
in an interview with Al Jazeera mali's
prime minister says the mission is not
delivering on its mandate to protect the
population
we want to make our people safe the
International Community intervened in
Mali following the adoption of a U.N
security Council resolution in 2013.
Marlins understood it was to end the war
as soon as a peace agreement was signed
they said they were here to bring peace
but there is no peace to bring soldiers
are dying we want to stop the mass
killings of our soldiers and of our
citizens
forces from several European countries
have left the U.N mission after mali's
Junta hired Russian mercenaries from the
Wagner group to support its own troops
U.N independent human rights experts
accuse fighters from Wagner of carrying
out extrajudicial killings and torturing
people in Mali they are meant to protect
and so the U.N security Council is
meeting to discuss the future of the
mission at stake is the fate of a people
seemingly alone and vulnerable in the
face of mounting violence
the U.N Secretary General Antonio
Gutierrez has criticized Malia and
mali's Military agenda ahead of this U.N
security Council meeting in a statement
he said that he urged a return to a
civilian Rule now elections are supposed
to take place in February 2024 but he
also said that he deplored what he
described as the persistent paralysis in
the peace agreement that was signed in
2015 with many of the Armed groups not
respecting the peace agreement and
continuing to fight in the North in the
center of the country he deplored what
he described as or he denounced what he
described as a climate of deep mistrust
so this U.N security Council that will
be chaired by Russia a close Ally to
Mali well that will be the issue at hand
who to trust is the you it will the U.N
peacekeeping Mission be able to deliver
on its mandate that's what the Malian
people want or the Malian Authority want
whilst the U.N peacekeeping Mission want
to see the Malian Authority keep to its
promise all right back to you Doreen
thank you so much Nicholas Hawk
reporting from Dakar